CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
I'm Claire Hughes Johnson.
It is very exciting to be here
to host Adelle Waldman, who
happens to be my sister-in-law.
ADELLE WALDMAN: [LAUGH]
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
My brother and my husband
are also here.
It's a family event, today.
But we couldn't be more proud
of Adelle and pursuing her dream
and realizing it-- woo!
--with this novel.
But hopefully many more.
I'll give a little
bit of an intro,
so folks have a
background on Adelle,
and then she's going to read
a bit from "The Love Affairs."
And then we'll just
do a little bit of Q&A
and invite folks in the
room to ask questions.
So Adele went to Brown
University-- grew up
in Baltimore.
She went to Brown
University-- go, Bruno.
I happened to, also,
go to Brown University.
And she worked as a reporter
for the "New Haven Register"
and also the Cleveland
"Plain Dealer"
and then moved to New York
and started writing and doing
other things.
Yes?
Is that accurate, or not?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Yeah.
That sounds pretty good.
There was some SAT
tutoring, in there.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: SAT tutoring,
to make some bucks
on the side, there.
As a writer, you need to make
some bucks in other ways,
often.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Exactly.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And has
written for a few publications,
like "Village Voice," and
some bigger ones, coming up,
I think.
But-- other ones?
ADELLE WALDMAN:
Many publications,
as many a freelance
writer has experienced.
But I've written book reviews
for the "New York Times"
and the "Wall Street Journal"
and "The New Republic."
And I'm working for something
for "The New Yorker," now,
but-- this and that, mixed
with-- well, this and that.
[LAUGH]
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Yeah, mixed with-- right.
We'll have Adelle tell
us a little bit more
about the writing process,
once she reads from the book.
This book-- which we've highly
publicized in our notes--
has been named a Book
of the Year, last year,
by anybody you can name.
"The Economist," NPR, "Elle,"
"Vogue," "The Washington
Post"-- I don't know.
It was, like, a huge list
that is incredibly impressive.
It is-- on the
paperback version,
here, which is the
first I've seen.
I ordered some from Amazon.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Oh!
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
--says "National Bestseller."
So that is pretty rock-star.
And is, I think, viewed
as a great success
and has gotten a lot of
attention in articles as well,
for various reasons, which,
maybe, we'll get into.
But one of them,
of course, is, it's
written from the
male perspective,
and people find
interesting when they
meet Adelle, who is one
of the nicest, greatest,
non-male people [LAUGHTER]
(LAUGHING) that I know.
So we'll get into that.
But why don't we
do a quick reading,
and then I'll ask
some questions.
Sound good?
All right.
Great.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Well,
thank you for that intro.
That was the loveliest intro--
and the most personal one.
I've never been introduced
by a family member.
That was nice!
So I'm going to say a few
words, before I start reading,
if that's OK.
So the book-- as
the title suggests--
"The Love Affairs
of Nathaniel P."--
it's kind of obvious that the
book is going to be about this
guy's love life.
Nathaniel P. is a
writer in New York.
He's in his early 30s,
and he is achieving
some professional success,
when the book begins.
And when he was in his 20s,
he was a struggling freelance
writer; I can
relate to that part.
But he wasn't that
popular with women.
He's, like, a fine-looking
guy, but he's not
the best-looking guy.
But as he's hit 30 and
he started to do better,
professionally, he's
becoming more popular
with women, and that is
having mixed consequences.
In the past few
years, he sort of
had a habit of
pissing women off.
And he's got a
number of exes who
aren't super-pleased with him.
So he's not a terrible guy.
He doesn't wake up in
the morning and think,
I am going to hurt women today.
But he has a number
of ex-girlfriends
who aren't too pleased with him.
So the section I'm
reading, though,
is not about Nathaniel--
or, as he's often called,
Nate-- in New York; it's
backstory about the days
before he got to
be this guy, when
he was in high
school and college.
And, well, he was
different, back then.
And all you need to
know-- all that's happened
is that, in the
first chapter, Nate
has run into an ex-girlfriend
on the streets of Brooklyn,
and the encounter did
not go super-well.
It ended with her calling him
an asshole and storming off.
So this is chapter two.
"Nate had not always been
the kind of guy women
call an asshole.
Only recently had he
been popular enough
to inspire such ill will.
Growing up, he had
been considered nice.
He was also a wunderkind of
advanced placement classes,
a star debater, and a fledgling
songwriter whose extra-credit
homage to Madonna, for
Math Appreciation Week--
"Like a Cosine, Solved for
the Very First Time"-- had,
unfortunately, been broadcast
to the entire upper school.
Despite playing on the varsity
soccer and baseball teams
since 10th grade-- granted,
his was a Jewish day school--
Nate never quite achieved
the reputation of an athlete.
He didn't repel girls, exactly.
They sought him out for
help with Bio or Calculus--
even for advice about
their personal problems.
They flirted with him when
they wanted an ego boost,
and then they told him
about their crushes
on Todd, or Mike, or Scott.
Nate wasn't much to
look at, back then.
Dark-haired and skinny, he
had a pale, sunken chest
that, he felt, made
him look cowardly,
as if he were perpetually
shrinking back.
Though he wasn't painfully
short, he wasn't tall, either.
His, hands, eyebrows,
nose, and Adam's apple
appeared to have been intended
for a much larger person.
This caused him to
hold out hope, even
as high school progressed,
that he might spring up
another couple inches into
the five-foot double digits.
In the meantime,
though, these attributes
didn't add much to his existing
stock of personal charms.
Todd and Mike and Scott were
Nate's soccer and baseball
teammates.
Scott was the most popular
guy in their class.
He was tall and broad-shouldered
and had that combination
of crudeness and confidence that
rendered intelligence not only
irrelevant but
slightly ridiculous--
a peculiar, if not
entirely unamusing, talent,
like the ability
to ride a unicycle.
Todd and Mike and
Scott were not exactly
Nate's friends, at least
not on terms of equality.
But they thought he was funny.
They also relied on him
for help with calculus.
Todd and Mike did,
anyway; Scott never
made it past trigonometry.
Nate went to their parties.
Nate got drunk.
Jokes were made about how funny
it was Nate-- bard of the math
department, with a
4.0 GPA-- was drunk.
Meanwhile, Nate pined for
girls like Amy Perlman--
the stacked blonde
siren of their class,
whose bashfully averted
eyes and modest smile
were nicely offset by her clingy
sweaters and ass-hugging jeans.
Naturally, Amy went out with
Scott, although, one day,
she confided to Nate that she
was worried about their future.
'I mean, what will
become of him?
Like, if his dad's stores'--
liquidated designer goods--
'don't keep doing well,
my dad says they're, like,
overleveraged.
But Scott can barely read.
And I mean, he can read;
just not, like, whole books.
But I can't see him
doing well in college
and getting a regular job.
It just wouldn't
be him, you know?'
In retrospect, it
wasn't surprising
that Amy Perlman-- who was
not actually stupid, but only
affected stupidity
in her speech,
because that was the fashion--
eventually ditched Scott
and got an MBA from Wharton.
At the time, however, Nate
had, somewhat to his surprise,
come to Scott's defense.
'He's a good guy, though, and
he really likes you.' Amy looked
thoughtful but not
quite convinced.
"I guess."
Meanwhile, Nate did have one
admirer during high school--
frizzy-haired
Michelle Goldstein.
It wasn't that
Michelle wasn't pretty.
He'd been interested in girls
who looked worse, anyway.
But there was something
painfully self-conscious
about her.
While it should have been
refreshing to see someone
at their school
engrossed in Mary
Woolstonecraft's 'A
Vindication of the Rights
of Women,' Michelle's embrace of
culture seemed a bit affected.
She had an inexplicable
fondness for the phrase 'pas de
deux,' which Nate had once--
frighteningly enough--
overheard her use in reference
to her relationship with him.
Still, at moments, he felt
real affection for Michelle.
One spring night--
it must have been
after a school play
or concert-- they
sat together for hours on a
bench outside the upper school,
gazing down a grassy hill
toward the dark expanse
of the athletic fields.
Michelle spoke
intelligently-- touchingly--
about the music she liked--
moody female singer-songwriters
with socially
progressively lyrics--
and of her intention to live in
New York one day, to go, often,
to The Strand-- 'a
huge used bookstore,
downtown,' she explained.
Nate wasn't sure if he'd even
been to a used bookstore.
There weren't any, in their
suburb, he didn't think.
'You should go to New York
some time,' Michelle said.
'I've been; we didn't go
anyplace like that.' From his
family's weekend in New
York, Nate had photos,
taken by his Dad, of
him and his mother,
huddled together on the
observation deck of the Empire
State Building.
They wore newly
purchased ponchos
and smiled warmly while a cold
drizzle fell on their heads.
Michelle smiled sympathetically.
In the light that spilled
over from the parking lot,
Nate thought Michelle's
freckles and straw-colored hair
were cute.
He nearly reached
out across the bench
and touched her-- her
hand, or her thigh.
It wasn't even about sex.
Nate's life had been somewhat
short on friendship--
real friendship,
distinct from the sort
of conditional alliance he
had with Scott and company.
Sitting on the bench
with Michelle, Nate
felt as if the two of
them shared something--
some nebulous, slightly
melancholic sensitivity
that made them different
from their classmates.
But at school, on
Monday, Michelle
seemed to have reverted
back to her other self.
'I can't believe you got an A
on that test,' she said after
calculus.
'What a coup d'etat.' She gave a
little wave as she walked away.
'Ciao, cheri.' '"Coup,"'
Nate wanted to shout;
'you mean just plain "coup."'
Yet he and Michelle were
constantly lumped together
and treated as a couple.
Scott repeatedly asked
him if her cooter
smelled like mothballs, because
of all the vintage clothes
she wore.
Michelle's ambiguous
social status--
neither cool nor uncool--
apparently made her
his female equivalent.
They even went to
senior prom together.
Nate had been
working up the nerve
to ask a pretty
sophomore, and he
felt both resentment and
relief when Michelle's
asking him foreclosed
that possibility.
On prom night, he thought
Michelle might even
have been willing to have sex.
But he didn't really try--
although they made out.
Well, more than
made out, actually.
He had a brief opportunity
to assess Scott's hypothesis
vis-a-vis the bouquet
of her female parts.
But Nate didn't push, because,
at that particular moment
in his life, he didn't
want to get entangled
with a girl who was
slightly repulsive to him.
Nor could he imagine
sleeping with Michelle
and then blowing her off, the
way that Todd or Mike might
have-- although not Scott,
who, for all his crudity,
was sensitive and unwavering
in his devotion to Amy.
There was something that
rubbed Nate wrong about Todd
and Mike's attitude toward
girls-- their implicit belief
that whatever befell a foolish
or unattractive one was
her just desserts.
Empathy they reserved for
the best-looking girls.
Amy Perlman's most minor
setbacks-- a B+ or mild cold--
elicited coos of grave concern.
Besides, by prom, Nate had
largely begun to pin his erotic
hopes on college,
where, he imagined,
even girls who looked like
Amy Perlman would be smart
and, more important, mature--
a word he had lately begun
to interpret as 'willing
to have sex with him.'
If he were to list the biggest
disappointments of life,
freshman year of
college would be
near the top, right
behind the realization--
much later-- that even something
as seemingly sublime as a blow
job-- his penis, in
a woman's mouth--
could be boring-- even
slightly unpleasant--
under the wrong circumstances,
or performed inexpertly."
And I think I'm
going to leave off,
at that slightly
embarrassing note.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't quite
realize what it would
be like to be reading that
in such a brightly lit room--
[LAUGHTER]
--at 1:00 PM.
I do a lot of readings at
night; the lights are dim--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
At night, at bookstores--
this doesn't feel like a cozy
bookstore; sorry! [LAUGH]
[LAUGHTER]
So let's talk a little
bit, and then, definitely,
think of questions,
for those who are here.
First about the book,
and then, maybe,
a little bit about
getting to the book.
You are always
asked this question,
but, I think, it
is one to-- why did
you choose to write
from Nate's perspective?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
I love this question.
So Nate is-- he's
a guy, and I'm not.
And that's, like, the
most-- in some ways,
the most salient
fact about the book.
And I did that, in part, because
I had this sense, one day.
I was reading a book
by a male author that
was, among other things,
about his relations--
or about the male
character's relationships.
And I was lying at a park,
near my apartment, reading,
and I had this feeling this--
sort of like a light bulb going
off in my mind-- that
I felt like I knew more
about this guy's emotional
life than he did.
And I felt that I
did, because I spent
my 20s dating various
people, some of whom
were better to date
than others, and trying
to analyze these bad boyfriends.
And talking to my friends
about their bad boyfriends,
and to my male friends,
about their relationships.
And I felt like
sometimes the problem
was that these guys were
not actually taking the time
to think about why they were
doing what they were doing.
So I had this
thought; it was, like,
I think I could use all
this insight I have--
all these years I've spent
thinking about these guys,
and put it into a book.
But that seemed kind of crazy.
So it was this idea,
in the back of my mind.
And I just thought I
would-- it was, almost,
like a joke, or a dare.
But I kept coming back to it.
And then I started to
combine that with this idea
that I felt that I'd read
a lot of books-- books
that I love-- by male authors,
like Philip Roth, and Saul
Bellow, and more modern
male authors, as well.
But about a young man who
is smart and ambitious,
and comes to the city to
conquer it with his intellect,
and cuts a wide swath through
the female population.
And, usually, he's really--
he's charming, as a protagonist.
And as readers, we identify with
him and sympathize with him.
But I think that, oftentimes,
the way these guys
treat women isn't
really scrutinized.
And I thought, wouldn't it
be neat to write a book that
follows that same archetype
but really pays attention
to how this man treats women?
And so I decided
to give it a try.
I thought I would just
try a chapter or two,
to see how it went.
And then, four years later,
there was a book. [LAUGH]
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: That's great.
So Nate is not the most
appealing protagonist.
And I also think it's funny,
because a lot of the male
reviewers-- particularly
those who live in New York,
or who are in this,
sort of, writing scene,
if you will-- kind of said,
oh, I recognize myself. [LAUGH]
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
I thought, how are they
dealing with that fact, that
they're recognizing themselves
in-- because he is very
real, but he's also
hard to deal with.
If any of you have
read the book,
it's a fascinating exercise,
'cause it's so well-written,
and you're interested
in what's happening,
but you also want to punch him.
I-- at least for me.
I'll speak for myself.
Occasionally, I
wanted to punch him.
ADELLE WALDMAN: And
you're not the only one,
Claire; it's not some especially
violent tendency on your part.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: [LAUGH]
ADELLE WALDMAN: I've heard
that from many, many women.
And definitely from
certain men, too.
So there is an interesting
gender divide, I think,
in response to the book.
Because, I think,
men tend to say
that they relate a
little bit to Nate.
But they're not proud of it.
They don't read this book and
they're not like, oh, yes!
That's me!
They see some of
their-- some habits
that they're not so proud of.
And I think, by
virtue of the guy
saying that he-- he, kind
of, winces with recognition,
in reading the book-- I
think that, by virtue,
make these guys
better than Nate,
because they're more self-aware.
But women, also,
sometimes-- I think--
respond in a way that is,
maybe, wincing or cringing,
but it's not because they
recognize themselves, in Nate,
but they recognize men
they've dated, in Nate.
And so there's that divide.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Yeah.
ADELLE WALDMAN: But, yeah.
I tried, in writing the book,
not to think very much about
whether I liked Nate or not.
I just, really, wanted
him to feel real.
And I wanted him to be a
slippery as any ex-boyfriend
that I or my friends
had ever had,
and to not be completely
bad or completely good.
And I have to say
it's whether I--
There are aspects
of Nate that I like.
I have this moral
critique of him,
but I don't hate him,
across the board.
And I wanted to be fair to him.
I didn't want to make him
just a standard villain.
I wanted to make him
someone that-- men wouldn't
read the book and
think, oh, this sounds
like a bitter ex-girlfriend's
revenge fantasy.
That would undercut the purpose.
So I think Nate-- or, I
hope he's complicated.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: He's
definitely complicated, though.
It struck me as a very
intelligent, bitter (LAUGHING)
ex-girfriend's revenge
fantasy, possibly.
[LAUGHTER]
But frankly, Hannah-- the
female protagonist-- though,
obviously, not as central
as Nate, in the book,
but very important--
is not faultless.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
I mean, I think
that's the other thing, is,
you're kind of-- if you're
a woman-- for me,
reading the book,
I'm kind of wanting
to have my older self,
say, knock some sense
into her, as well.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Absolutely.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
And did you--?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Yeah.
So, in the book, there's
one main relationship
that takes up the
arc of the plot.
And it's-- Nate starts dating
this woman named Hannah.
And their relationship
starts off
with a fair amount of promise.
Hannah's a little bit
skeptical of him, at first.
He's, kind of, got a rap
as a womanizer, these days.
So she's skeptical.
But he seems very into
it and wins her trust,
and she lets her guard down.
And things are good,
for a little while.
And then Nate just
starts losing interest.
It starts really subtly.
He doesn't even know why
it's happening, at first.
And so he can't explain why.
And Hannah starts to
sense that, and that
makes her feel insecure.
And as she feels a
little bit insecure,
he becomes a little
irritated by her insecurity.
It's the cycle.
And it was really important, to
me, to write about that cycle,
because I felt like it
was something familiar.
And I don't think it's only
men who behave like Nate.
I think we've all been
a Nate, and we've all
been a Hannah,
regardless of our gender.
But I felt like
it can be hurtful,
if you're in Hannah's
position, if you've
come to care about
someone, and then
you sense them pulling away,
and you don't know why.
And I've definitely heard from
a lot of readers who have--
and women readers-- who
are disappointed in Hannah,
because she does-- she
gets more insecure,
and she becomes
weaker and needier.
And I think, as a woman,
you read the book,
and you just want
to tell-- you want
her to kick him to the curb.
And I wish she would.
I, too, feel the same
way that Claire did.
But it was important
to me that she not
do that, because I felt
that, ironically, it
would be letting
Nate off the hook,
if Hannah got away too unhurt.
That I felt, like, to show
how hurtful his behavior is,
I had to show its
effect on Hannah.
It gets under her skin.
He's not so bad that she-- that
she can just break up with him,
instantly.
She's trying to--
she likes him; she's
trying to make the best of.
And he does things
like-- like, she asks him
if something is wrong, because
she senses something is wrong,
and he says no-- but
in a tone of voice that
clearly suggests there is.
And I think that
can be maddening.
And it's hard to know.
It's, like, do you
break up with a person
because they're being a
little cool or distant?
But maybe they've just had a bad
day, or maybe they're stressed.
So I felt like it was really
important to, kind of,
allow Hannah to really
run the gamut and be her.
And she, ultimately, does-- ooh,
I shouldn't give away too much.
But I understand
that frustration.
I, too, wish I could shake
Hannah and get her to break up
with Nate, and Nate
could, sort of, earlier
get the comeuppance he
definitely deserves.
But I didn't think that would
serve my purpose in being
realistic, and, also, in showing
just how harmful Nate's-- that
kind of behavior can be,
for the other person.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: So-- well, I
will say-- if you
haven't read the book,
there are these, like, moments
in Nate's inner monologue.
First of all, he assesses
every woman, physically, [SNAP]
immediately, which, you have
to believe, is happening.
[LAUGHTER]
But also, things
like-- the pillows
on her bed bug the
crap out of him.
And, like, how she's
decorated-- you know,
these moments are very
specific and exactly right.
There's also been a
question, that I get,
which is, is there any
of your brother in Nate?
And the answer I give is, I
think his hideous apartment--
ADELLE WALDMAN: [LAUGH]
[LAUGHTER]
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
(LAUGHING) --is, potentially,
drawn from my brother's
excellent housekeeping skills.
But I won't put you on
the spot too much on that.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: But you've
probably had to deal with,
how did you create Nate, and--
ADELLE WALDMAN: Well, definite--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: --is
there a specific individual,
or--?
ADELLE WALDMAN: There is
no particular individual,
and certainly not
my kind husband,
Claire's brother, who--
[LAUGHTER]
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
She's, like, I
don't want to get
in trouble, here.
[LAUGHTER]
ADELLE WALDMAN: Perhaps
some very minor details,
such as the top of Nate's
dresser, I did, maybe,
peer at the top of
my husband's dresser,
to see what kind of
junk he kept on it.
But that's about it.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
And the hideous apartment.
ADELLE WALDMAN: [LAUGH]
But in a deeper way.
Nate-- the way he
sizes up women--
writing that was so
weird and painful.
And I had a good friend of
mine, who I'd give the novel to,
in chunks, when
I was writing it.
And I gave her the first
five chapters to read.
And then we met for a
drink, to discuss it.
And she was, like,
I have to tell you,
I'm feeling a little
uncomfortable.
When-- when I-- now
that I've read the book,
I feel like, when
we see each other,
are you checking out my breasts?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: [LAUGH]
ADELLE WALDMAN: And
I was, like, no!
And when I am writing,
and being Nate,
it's a totally different world.
When I'm back to
being Adelle, like,
the world looks normal again.
But I get that.
And some of what I wrote in
the book really disturbed me.
I felt, to do what
I wanted to do,
well enough, I had to put
my own feelings aside,
because a lot of
what Nate thinks
are, actually, the
things that I most feared
an ex-boyfriend would've thought
about me, when we were dating.
They weren't comforting
for me to imagine.
But I felt that there
was a reason to do that,
in part because I
didn't want it to read
like any kind of fantasy.
I wanted it to be a
serious book about dating.
And I don't think
that's an oxymoron.
I think many of us who spend
a good portion of our adult
lives single, in
this day and age,
and that the struggles of
finding the right person
and dating deserve to
be taken seriously.
They're not inherently
just frothy,
and the stuff of
romantic comedies.
I wanted to write, I felt,
a serious, if not always
comforting, book,
about these subjects.
And I got freaked out.
And the one story I love to
tell, about Evan-- Claire's
brother, my husband-- is,
there were times when I'd just
write something I felt
was so disturbing,
just, like, one of
Nate's fantasies,
or just he'd be sizing
up women's bodies.
And I would just be
in my little office,
and I'd get all disgusted.
And I'd come out,
and I'd see Evan,
and I'd just be mad at him for--
[LAUGHTER]
--being a guy.
And then Evan would
feel like it was unfair,
that I was mad at him for what I
made my imaginary character say
and do, in my imaginary world.
And I think he had a point.
But I had a point, too,
(LAUGHING) I think.
But yeah.
Wow.
Men.
But actually, I'll just
say-- men in the room--
they're-- I don't think
all men are as bad as Nate.
I do think Nate behaves in
some stereotypically male ways,
and that was important to me.
I didn't want to
write a male character
that, maybe, was
believable as a male,
but that sort of-- on the
far end of being feminine.
And I wanted to write, like, a
kind of uber-masculine guy who
does the things-- like, he
doesn't-- he's ambivalent about
wanting a relationship; he goes
out on a couple of really good
dates and then takes,
like, a week to call.
He, when asked if something
is wrong, he's apt to say no,
just 'cause he wants to
avoid a conversation.
And just behaviors that,
I felt, seemed-- not
typical of every
man-- and again, women
have-- we have our own.
Women do these things, as well.
But it was very interesting
to try to explore,
in a fair way, the thinking that
might underlie these behaviors.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: So I
don't want to give it away,
but I love the
ending of the novel.
I found it fascinating
when I learned
that some readers, including
more professional readers,
thought the ending
was a happy ending.
I'm not saying it's
an unhappy ending.
I think it's an ending that
really makes you think.
But how did you handle it, when
various reviewers or readers,
or even editors,
sort of made comments
about the novel that were
not, maybe, your intended--
or is that-- was
that exciting, to see
a different interpretation?
ADELLE WALDMAN: A
little bit of both.
So one of the challenges, for
me, in writing this novel,
is that it's all told
from Nate's perspective.
It's written in something
called the close third person.
So it's not first person;
I'm not writing, like,
"I this, I that"-- which would
be a little bit weird for me,
as a woman, to be
writing first person,
from Nate's perspective.
So it's close third.
It's always in his head.
You don't get the
perspectives-- you
don't get the inner thoughts
of any other character,
and there's no narrator
making judgments.
And that was really hard for
me, because I'm, actually,
a pretty moralistic, judgmental
person, in a lot of ways.
And I wanted to step
in and be, like, OK,
we know that when
Nate does this,
it's bad, for these reasons,
and he's been a jerk, here.
But I couldn't, because
it's in his head.
So I, also, felt like that left
open room for interpretation.
And there's a lot
of things that I
think about what
are wrong with Nate
that they're just--
they're not in the book.
And it's been very
interesting, for me,
to hear different
people's responses.
And I have a mixed reaction.
In some ways, it's exciting
when people read the book really
differently, because it makes
me feel that I have been fair,
that the ending was fair,
if some people can read it
as a happier ending and
some as a sadder ending.
It sort of depends how
you feel about the person
and the relationship Nate is in.
And I wanted it to be as
realistic as any relationship
that anyone we know might be in.
It's not 100% perfect, but
I don't think any of us
are in relationships that are.
And just-- you know,
just, like, relationships
with your friends, or
that a friend might have,
you might think, ah, she could
have done a little bit better.
But then, someone else might
be, like, no, no, no, they're
pretty happy.
So I wanted it to
feel like that.
So in the one sense,
it's gratifying,
if there's a variety
of responses;
I feel like I wasn't
too heavy-handed
and didn't force my perspective.
On the other hand, there are
moments, it's frustrating.
I'm like, what?
I totally wanted everyone
to think this other thing.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
That's very honest.
So let's talk a minute about--
you got a novel published.
That's a big deal.
So can you tell me a little bit
about your journey to that--
ADELLE WALDMAN: Sure.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: --and
career choices you made?
We always like to have talks
about career development,
at Google.
(LAUGHING) And so-- this is
a very non-Googly career,
(LAUGHING) that
Adelle has developed.
And I think it's
pretty fascinating.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
Well, I graduated from
college with the desire
to write a novel.
The problem was,
I had zero ability
to actually write a
novel, at that point.
I somehow thought that it
wouldn't be as hard as it was.
But soon after I graduated
from college, I realized,
I don't know why I had
thought I could just do this,
and it would just work.
So I went into journalism
as a good day job--
as something that
seemed kind of fun.
I knew people who
worked as journalists.
I thought it could
only help my writing,
and I'd learn more
about the world.
And it turned out to be great.
And I spent my 20s working
in-- I first started
a financial trade
publication, and then moved
from there to the "New
Haven Register" newspaper,
in Connecticut.
And it was great.
It was a lot of fun.
But in the back of
my mind, I always
wanted to be a novelist,
which wasn't great, you know,
when you do those
job interviews.
And they're like, where do you
see yourself in five years?
I'd be, like,
novel-- no-- I would
like to be covering
international affairs
for the "New York
Times." [LAUGH]
So it was always on my mind.
And then, when I was about 29,
maybe, it was freaking me out.
Like, oh my god, am I going
to spend my whole life
as a person-- when the back of
my mind wants to write novels,
but never does?
I decided to take a bold step.
I was writing a column, for
the wallstreetjournal.com,
about twentysomethings'
personal finances.
And I quit that gig, and
I wrote my last column
about how I was going
to sublet my apartment
and move in with my
parents and spend
six months writing a novel.
And I did.
And the amazing thing is,
I actually wrote a novel.
And I had never written
anything that had more than,
like, 30 pages before I gave
up, because it was horrible.
And it really was-- what
I'd written-- was horrible.
So just the fact that I'd
actually finished one,
in six months, blew me away.
And I was a little
bit unrealistic
about what would happen next.
I came back to New York
at the end of six months.
My subletters moved out.
I thought-- I thought it would
be just a matter of months
before I got an agent,
that novel was sold,
I was on-- being interviewed
by Terry Gross, on "Fresh Air,"
I never had to work again--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: [INAUDIBLE].
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: [INAUDIBLE]
did not exist, then, I
realize, in your life.
ADELLE WALDMAN:
(LAUGHING) Right.
I mean, I just
thought-- this is great.
I'm done.
So it didn't actually
proceed that smoothly.
And I moved back to New
York, and I had decided--
since I was only going to
be nonfamous for six weeks,
or something-- that I--
[LAUGHTER]
--should, um-- I'd just get a
job tutoring as an SAT tutor,
because it just seemed
like, why bother
to try to land another
journalism job,
for such a short time?
I wound up being an SAT
tutor for six years.
It didn't go as planned.
So that novel didn't
find a publisher,
and it took me
awhile to realize,
that's actually for the best.
At the time, I was devastated;
definitely devastated.
But, over time, I saw
that I had learned a lot
from writing that novel,
but it really-- it
wasn't ready to be published.
And, eventually I
met Evan, my husband.
And I'd like to give
them credit for this,
that he, sort of, pushed
me to start another novel.
He said, well, you
can't just always dwell
on the novel that
didn't get published,
if you want to be a novelist.
Now you know you
can write a novel,
and why not start another?
And that led to my
starting this one.
And it took a lot longer
than six months, which I hope
is good for the
quality of the novel.
[LAUGH] I wound up taking
about four years to write it.
And in that time, I
found a literary agent,
who's a person who, then, takes
it to publishers and sells it.
And she sold it very nicely and
quickly-- which was gratifying,
after my last experience.
So, all told, it was
four years of writing,
and then there was
about another year
before it actually
appeared, because publishing
takes a long time.
So it was about
five years from when
I started writing to when
it actually was a book.
In which time, I
think that many people
in my life, understandably,
were sick of hearing
me talk about this novel that
never seemed to go anywhere.
It was just a Microsoft
Word document.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
And then you, kind of,
achieved that dream you
had with your first novel,
which is this recognition.
And it is unusual for a first
novel to get the attention
and acclaim that "The Love
Affairs" has received.
ADELLE WALDMAN: That's true.
Although--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Did
that strike you as gratifying,
or do you know that that
(LAUGHING) was unusual?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Well, now--
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: I know you
know that, intellectually, but--
ADELLE WALDMAN: Now,
I absolutely do,
but at the time-- I mean,
during the first novel-- I mean,
the thing is, I don't think
I've ever achieved the glory I
thought I would with
the first novel,
because I was so unrealistic--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Oh, because there's
Terry Gross involved.
Right.
OK.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
And I just thought-- this "never
having to work again" thing--
I didn't, really, quite
understand the economics of it.
[LAUGH] So maybe I'll
always be striving
for that dream of glory.
But no, no; it's been great.
And I think it's been
good that, over the years,
I learned more about
the publishing industry,
and my expectations
have been moderated.
And then, certainly, the
response to this novel
has exceeded my expectations
in so many ways that
have been extremely gratifying.
But I also think it was
healthier to think smaller--
and to realize, too, that the
main part of writing a novel
is, actually, the writing of
it; the time it's just you,
sitting there, at the computer.
And that part is, actually,
really fun and gratifying.
And I think that has to be the
main thing, because you never
know what will happen
with the response.
Or sales; very mysterious.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Yes.
Mysterious sales.
And you're now on-- so you
did, sort of, a little bit
of a tour, when it
was out in hardcover.
And now, the way it
works is, they send you
on another tour-- yes?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
For paperback?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: The whole
publishing thing is, actually,
fascinating, if you don't work
(LAUGHING) in that industry.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Interesting.
Yeah.
So I was in Portland on Monday
night, and Seattle last night.
And then a place
called Corte Madera--?
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: Corte Madera.
ADELLE WALDMAN: --tonight.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Tonight.
ADELLE WALDMAN: And
Oakland, tomorrow.
So it's exciting.
And fun.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: So
you go to these bookstores,
and you read.
And do you sign them, and
you, kinda, chat with people?
Do weird people show up?
What kind of people show up?
ADELLE WALDMAN: All right.
I'm going to give you the
really candid answer, if you
don't mind.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
This is getting recorded.
ADELLE WALDMAN: So Monday night,
I did the reading in Portland,
at Powell's Bookstore--
famous bookstore.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: Very iconic.
ADELLE WALDMAN: It was great.
It was so much fun.
A good crowd came; the
questions were great.
This was really good.
And I've done a lot of
readings, at this point.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Was
it, like, young hipsters,
basically?
Or what was the--
ADELLE WALDMAN: Actually,
an interesting mix.
I remember two people in
line-- you do a signing, after.
So you talk to people
who buy the books
and want me to sign them
and chat for a minute.
There were two
women who said they
were buying the books to help
them understand their sons,
and that they thought
that they might
give the book to their sons.
And I think they had read
about it in an alt weekly,
in Portland, which had
just run an interview.
So there were-- and
there were some, sort of,
older people-- um-- a mix.
And then younger-- the younger
hipster crowd, definitely.
And there's always an
interesting gender mix,
I have to say, at readings.
And one thing that has also
been gratifying, to me,
is that, when you write a
book about relationships,
there's the perception
that it's for women.
That only women care about it.
And I have to say, my book
is-- I think, actually, men
might like it better, maybe
because Nate is hard to like,
as a woman.
I get-- a lot of the reviews
have been written by men,
and I get-- about
2/3 of the letters
I get are, actually, from guys,
saying they relate to Nate,
and they see their thoughts
reflected on the page.
But again, what I
also think, that
does make them better than Nate,
because they're self-aware.
But I also feel like it's
just gratifying, in its way,
to think, men do care
about relationships.
This is a book--
there is no B-plot.
It's all about relationships.
There's no terrorism,
there are no police chases,
there's no cigars
or whisky-- well,
there's a little whisky--
but, you know-- I don't know.
So that's been neat.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: So you were
telling-- Portland was great.
So maybe not
everywhere is great.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Oh my god.
So, then I went to
Seattle, last night.
And Seattle has a great
bookstore-- Elliott Bay
Bookstore.
And wow, I-- it was just a
very, very different crowd.
And nobody laughed, and the
questions felt kind of hostile.
It was just so different.
And I don't know if
it just-- who comes.
Maybe it was a beautiful
day in Seattle,
and the reading was in
a downstairs basement.
Maybe people were in a
bad mood from being there.
Maybe I read horribly.
I don't know.
But it can vary.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: What is a
hostile question, to an author?
I mean--
ADELLE WALDMAN: I don't-- I
guess it-- it will just be,
like, why-- why are your
characters (LAUGHING)
so pretentious?
[LAUGHTER]
It's pretty--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: I
did, almost, ask you a very--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
--actually.
Because there is
some intellectual
snobbery-- right? --in Nate
and his circle of friends.
And it's fascinating
to watch him
be so obsessed with
women's breasts, and then,
the next moment, be
thinking about how
to write about the income
(LAUGHING) inequality--
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
--in radical, new ways.
And I wondered if people
found that off-putting.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Because that group
is-- that's not most people's
circle of friends, right?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
Yeah, I really think that's
been a factor, with this book.
And I don't know
what to say about it.
When I set out to
write the book,
I felt like I wanted to write
the book-- the book that I
was most interested in writing.
And I didn't think it
would be good, as a writer,
to start thinking about,
what would appeal to the most
amount of people,
and how could I
create the most
relatable character.
I thought if I could make the
character be very particular,
I would hope that it
would speak to people.
And I guess I was
also interested,
as a writer, living in New York,
in a particular subculture--
there's this, sort of,
intellectual sexism, among men,
that interested me.
And I was around
guys who, I felt,
presume themselves to be, sort
of, intellectual inheritors
of greatness, in this
way that, I felt,
that the women in
our circle, who
are equally motivated
and intelligent
and well-read-- I just don't
know if we see ourselves
in quite the same terms.
And I really wanted
to explore that
without completely demonizing
Nate, but trying to flesh out
some of his more
sexist thoughts.
That he's not a monster, doesn't
state these things aloud.
He doesn't think women should
be barefoot and pregnant
in the kitchen.
But he has some
intellectual sexism.
So that was important,
to me, to explore,
but there is a flip
side-- is that, it's just
a book set among a
self-consciously intellectual
crowd.
And I understand why
that puts people off.
I mean, it puts off people,
including my parents, I think,
a little.
They think-- they
think it's pretentious.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
what about your friends?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Oh,
well, I think-- oh-- huh.
How do I answer this without
seeming to undercut my friends?
Are we all pretentious,
that (LAUGHING) we--?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: I'm
not calling your friends
pretentious--
ADELLE WALDMAN: No, no!
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: --but
I wonder if they think, oh,
that's me, and that's her, and--
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
Um, I think I've been
very, very lucky.
And I was also careful,
in writing the book,
to try to make sure
that the book was true
to a general
subculture, but not--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
--yours, specifically.
ADELLE WALDMAN:
--implicate individuals,
because that seemed-- it's just
not the-- the book has kind
of-- Nate's tone is
not always very nice,
and the thing-- I mean,
it's often not very nice.
The way he thinks about
people-- I would never
want any particular person to
read the book and think Nate
was thinking that
way about them.
So I feel like all the
characters are very carefully
designed to not be real people.
But one thing-- I have to say
this-- a good friend mine,
from high school-- who's not
in this subculture, at all--
he read an early
copy of the book.
And he said he liked
it, but he told me,
after the book was published,
that he was very, very
relieved at the way
it was received.
Because, he said,
that, when he read it,
he thought people in my
world-- writers in Brooklyn--
would be horrified, because it
portrays them so negatively,
and that I'd be,
kind of, cast out.
And he was just worried for my
sake, but-- what would I do?
Actually, it hasn't
been like that at all.
And that has been-- luckily, I
didn't-- if I had expected what
Matt expected for me, I would
have been so much more nervous.
But that I think
that even people
in this literary
Brooklyn world get
a kick out of seeing
recognizable types.
Or, in any case, people
have been very nice to me,
about the book, in Brooklyn.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: That's great.
Any questions?
I'll let you guys
think about that.
All right.
We've got a lot of questions.
Right.
We'll start over here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADELLE WALDMAN: Mhm.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
I'm going to just
restate the question, quickly.
So the comment was--
without giving a lot away--
the book has a long relationship
and a shorter relationship,
and the longer relationship
is a richer one
and also gets more
time in the book.
And was that intentional,
in terms of time,
as well as how you
perceived the relationship?
Is that a fair restatement?
ADELLE WALDMAN: OK.
I think this is
a great question.
It's only tricky
for me to answer it
in a way that is
meaningful to those
who have read the book,
without giving too much away.
I'm going to try to do my best.
So when I conceived the book,
I knew from the very beginning
who Nate was going
to end up with.
And I wanted it to be not
obvious to readers, any more
than it was obvious to Nate.
And there's a basic
little plot I had in mind,
that I felt that, if I
could take-- I thought,
there's this thing that
happens, sometimes,
where-- this is from a
woman's perspective--
a woman in a heterosexual
relationship.
She's dating a guy, things
are good, for a while.
Then things are less good.
He seems to be pulling away.
She doesn't know why.
Things get worse and worse.
And then, they finally break up.
She is unhappy,
because she liked him.
But she tells herself that,
well, this guy, really,
has commitment issues.
So that's clearly the problem.
But then what happens--
like, a month later--
he's suddenly moving in with
someone else who seems, maybe,
less good for him, on paper.
And I thought-- I
felt like this was
a scenario that
seemed just common.
And I had heard of
it from friends.
So I thought, wouldn't
it be neat to dramatize
it-- to dramatize all
the players in it,
and to be fair to each of them?
So that played a role in
how I conceived the book.
So in some ways--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Because those things
happen quickly, those--
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
Like, the final relationship
happens quickly.
It takes a long time for, maybe,
a bad relationship to play out,
and a new relationship,
in this case,
seemed to happen more quickly.
So that's part of how I
saw the book's structure.
I also thought, after
spending so much time
on one relationship,
that I really
wanted to trace
this whole arc, it
would be tiresome
to do it again.
I think those are the-- that
might be the best I can do,
without giving too much away.
But I think it's
a good question,
because it's an odd
choi-- and it's-- people--
I do think the final chapter
does seem to come rather
quickly.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You've got a question?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about your
overall process [INAUDIBLE].
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
So the question
was the process-- was there an
outline or a structure in mind?
Was it iterative?
What did you start with?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Right.
Well, I had this basic
arc, that I just described,
of the relationship--
from beginning
to end-- that I wanted to show.
So I went with that.
And I did know, from
the very beginning,
who Nate was going
to end up with.
And so I put that chara--
well, sort of put her in,
early in the book, in
the way that I-- there's
this saying among
writers of-- it's
from Chekov, that
Chekov said, if there's
a gun in the first act, it has
to go off in the third act.
So I really wanted the
one Nate winds up with
to be there from the
beginning, but not
necessarily in a way you pay
attention to, at the time.
So in that sense, I was very
much aware of the structure,
from the beginning.
But that said,
that makes it sound
like I had so much more control
or knew what I was doing.
It took me so many years
to write this book, in part
because I had to go back
and play with the structure.
To try to get a relationship
in a slow decline,
the way Nate and
Hannah's eventually is,
was so hard for me.
I feel like it's something
we've all experienced-- again,
men or women, in real life.
But it's hard to
dramatize relationships
just getting slightly
worse, because, you know,
nothing happens.
There's no-- no
one cheats, there's
no violent fights,
where dishes are thrown.
It's sort of a series of
dinners that are a little bit--
something is off, and
they're kind of boring.
It was, like, how do I write
about this without making
the reader feel as bored as Nate
and Hannah do in the moment?
And to sort of get
that right, and try
to come up with scenes that
convey what's going on,
without being terribly
boring, was really tricky.
So it's like, I had
this overall structure,
but the microscenes
took me a long time.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Great.
Any other questions?
Back here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADELLE WALDMAN: Oh!
ADELLE WALDMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADELLE WALDMAN: Oh, thank you!
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: So the
first was a lovely compliment,
that this book is
recommended by our questioner
to his male friends.
And the other is-- so,
if you're not aware,
Adelle recently wrote-- is
"novella" the right word--?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ADELLE WALDMAN: I don't know.
It's--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
A short story?
ADELLE WALDMAN: --a long short
story, or a short novella.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
--called "New Year,"
from the perspective one of the
female characters of the book--
one of the friends
of Nate, who's
a woman who is a
fascinating character,
actually, in the book.
And why did that
happen, or how did
that come about--
kind of question.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Yeah,
so-- it's so interesting.
I didn't intend to write
this other short story, "New
Year's," exactly.
I had mentioned,
casually, to my publisher,
that I had a lot
more material on each
of the characters
in my book than,
actually, make it into the book.
Which is normal, I think.
As a writer, you
spend so many years
thinking about these characters.
So I knew-- you know, it
was fun for me to flesh out
the backstory of
all the characters,
even though it's not,
actually, in the book.
And the publisher-- the guy
whose title is, literally,
the publisher-- said, you know,
that might be fascinating.
Would you be interested in
taking some of this material
and putting it into a story?
And I said, no.
(LAUGHING) Absolutely not.
Because I thought the book
was an aesthetic whole.
It was very important to me
to keep it in its perspective.
I worried that another
perspective-- there
would be a temptation for
me to moralize too much.
I worried about all
sorts of things.
At the same time, as soon as
he had raised this possibility,
some part of my mind was a
little excited and intrigued
by it, because I really
loved writing this book,
and I loved thinking
about all the characters.
So it was a little
bit like an invitation
to go back to a world that
I'd had a lot of fun in.
And in the end, I was persuaded
to just give it a try.
And I said, OK, OK, I'll try it.
But I'm not going to
guarantee that we're
going to publish anything,
because I did have concerns.
And I wound up writing
from the perspective
of a character named
Aurit, who is sort
of a truth-telling
female friend of Nate.
She gives him a hard time about
the way he behaves with women.
And she was a very fun
character to write.
And it seemed fun to
inhabit her mindset.
And it was fun.
And I have to say, when I
sat down to write this story,
it took on a life of its own.
It wasn't something I
had thought I would do
or intended to do, but
once I started doing it,
I became invested in it.
But I still feel a little--
it's hard for me to explain it,
because it wasn't something
I ever thought I would do,
and yet, I really enjoyed it.
And I came to care
about the story.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Right.
Any final last question?
We're almost out of time.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
All right; great.
AUDIENCE: How did you
meet your literary agent?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Oh, great!
A practical question.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: How
did you meet the agent?
ADELLE WALDMAN: Well, when I had
written that first novel, that
didn't get published,
I didn't know anything
about book publishing.
It's funny; you
would have thought
that-- I lived in New York,
and I worked in newspapers--
that I would know a lot.
But there's, actually,
a pretty strict divide
between people in
the newspaper world
and in the publishing world.
And that's probably, too, why I
had these delusions of grandeur
about what was going to happen.
But at that point, I wrote
letters to literary agents
that I saw in directories
of literary agents.
You can buy them.
Now they're mostly online.
And you can also read the
acknowledgement pages of books,
to see who the author's
literary agent is.
I basically wrote--
I actually wrote
letters, when I think about it.
Some were paper letters.
There were some that were
email, but-- it was so long ago.
And that worked.
I got some responses.
People asked to see it.
But then many of them said
no to that particular book.
But by the time I wrote
this novel, one of my goals,
while writing it, was also to
learn more about the publishing
world, to be in
a better position
by the time I
finished the novel.
So I had tried to make an
effort to write book reviews
and get to know
people who were more
connected to the literary
world and publishing,
and to meet more
authors of books.
And that helped a lot.
Because this time,
when I wrote to agents,
I did do the same thing.
I sort of asked around, to find
out who some good agents were.
And I wrote emails.
But this time, I tended
to write emails that said,
my friend so-and-so,
who's one of your clients,
suggested I contact you .
And that, I have to
admit, helped a lot.
On the other hand, I did get
responses, even the first time.
I mean, I do think my first
novel was rejected because
of the contents, not because
I didn't know people.
But I do think-- if
anyone here is thinking
about these things-- I think
that it is, probably, true
that it can be helpful to
get a quicker response,
if you have some connection.
And that's unfortunate.
I mean, one shouldn't
have to live in New York
and hang out with writers
to get a quick response
from a literary
agent, but so it is.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: That's
true in many businesses, yes?
I see some nods in the room.
Well, thank you so
much, Adelle, and thanks
to all of you for
coming, and anyone
who joined us on
the live stream.
If you have not read
the book, I hope
you want to to, after this talk.
And, uh, have a great day.
Thanks.
ADELLE WALDMAN: Thanks, again.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks so much for being here.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Great.